so every type of mathematical object has
its own category
so there's a category of rings
whose objects include things like the
integers and the rational numbers
and the real numbers but then other
examples besides
so i'm using notation that'll be
familiar to mathematicians here
and any category in addition to its
objects has some notion of
transformation between those objects
which we draw
using arrows so these arrows represent
the inclusion for instance of the
rational numbers into the real numbers
the fundamental theorem of category
theory says that any mathematical object
no matter how complicated can be
understood can be characterized uniquely
by its relationship to the other objects
in its category
so for example in the category of rings
you might think of the integers as being
the numbers 0 1 2
negative 1 negative 2 together with
operations of addition and
multiplication but they're also uniquely
determined by the property that in the
category of the rings
there's a unique arrow from the integers
to any other ring
so you can think of a category as
providing a linguistic template for a
mathematical theory with nouns and verbs
but as the object's mathematicians study
get more complicated you need a more
robust linguistic template with
adjectives and adverbs and so on
and that's the idea of an infinity
category
so for example there's a category of
infinity rings
and like an ordinary category this one
has
objects and arrows so the examples have
some different names
but in addition to the objects and the
arrows which we think of as being zero
and one-dimensional
we have two-dimensional arrows arrows
between arrows that i draw
in this way and i think of as inhabiting
a two-dimensional space
and then there are also arrows between
arrows between arrows which we think of
as inhabiting the three-dimensional
space and arrows between arrows between
arrows between arrows and so on
all the way up this gets a little bit
harder to draw on paper
so mathematicians would like to use
infinite dimensional categories use
infinity categories to help systemize
their work in the way that
mathematicians are using ordinary
categories today
but the challenge with this is that it's
very difficult to write down the
definition of an infinity category
and in fact there are many competing
definitions which means that when
researchers
are proving theorems about infinity
categories they have to first pick a
specific definition
you can think of that as choosing
coordinates and then prove their
theorems in reference to that definition
so this provides a translation problem
you might ask if a theorem was proven
using one definition of infinity
categories
can be applied to an example of an
infinity category constructed in a
different definition
and even if that is possible
how exactly would that translation work
so this is the problem that i've been
working to solve with a collaborator
dominic verity from macquarie university
in sydney
and our approach is to apply the
philosophy of category theory to
category theory itself
so any type of mathematical object lives
in a category
these infinity categories are very
complicated objects themselves but if we
zoom out
we can think of them as living in their
own category
the category of infinity categories
and the category of infinity categories
has
some particular feature this universe in
which infinity categories live as
objects
we give it a name we call it an infinity
cosmos
so more precisely each model of infinity
categories
defines an infinity cosmos so if we
prove theorems about infinity cosmoy in
general then they specialize to give us
the theorems about
infinity categories proven in absolutely
every model and this is a way to
come up with a strategy for proving
theorems about infinity categories that
apply
universally